Jarell ham accepted the 2019 Sakharov
Prize for freedom of thought on behalf
of her father ill ham today currently
imprisoned in China since his arrest in
2014 the Weger scholar and human rights
activist is serving a life sentence for
alleged separatism Parliament elected
Emily O'Reilly as the European Ombudsman
for the next five years
the Ombudsman investigates
maladministration in EU institutions
article 21 of the EU s-- Charter of
Rights prohibits discrimination based on
sex or sexual orientation MEP is voted
on a resolution on hate speech against
the LGBTI community seventy percent of
world bees are at risk of extinction MEP
is voted to further reduce the use of
pesticides put more funds towards
research and improve monitoring in order
to save pollinators mep czar in favor of
lowering the threshold of minimum
taxable revenues for a digital company
to forty million euros Parliament wants
fairer taxation of digital services in
the light of global tax avoidance
practices